everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
set up a Google Cloud storage and we're
gonna get that connected so that it
works with WordPress
last week we we got set up so that
WordPress would work with Google Cloud
sequel so we did that just on a test
account and what I what I did earlier
today was I set up an official account
for my employer and I created a cloud
sequel database you know under that
account and today we're gonna set up the
storage bucket under that account as
well so everything that we had done
that's that's all all gone but we worked
out a lot of stuff with that I did
eventually get that working with I think
where we left off on Thursday we had
almost everything working so I ended up
getting it working the last little bit
that didn't work was just the the
ability for the WordPress installation
running on now to connect to that my
sequel database so with now the IP
addresses vary so much that you can't
just set an IP and have it access that
so I had to end up just allowing any IP
just to test it and make sure that it
worked and when I did that it did work
so what we'll do maybe not in today's
stream depending on how much time it is
but at some point we will set it up so
that we can allow different lots of
different IP addresses but then also
we'll have SSL setup as well so that
really like we only allow connections
that have the prop
keys so it'll still be secure but it
will also allow us to use now so that's
the plan but today we're gonna work on
storage we're gonna take a break from
the sequel stuff so let me get my
headphones on so I forgot to get this
set up I don't know if you've ever tried
to stream or anything or do videos but
there's just a really big difference
when you have headphones on and music
playing that as opposed like when you
don't I feel way more comfortable
talking whenever I have the headphones
on and the music playing so I'll get
that going
I do want to mention to you all well
first of all I I want to see I want to
say hello there's a lot of you you're
saying hello so yeah I am home today so
Christian yeah I'll be home today I'm
gonna be in the office tomorrow and the
next day so I have meetings and things
going on hopefully I'll have enough time
to stream though
all right cool got my spot if I go on
oh so one more thing I'd like to
announce I'm not gonna make a big deal
about this all the time but I'm just
gonna announce it maybe in the first
couple of streams just that everybody
knows I started a patreon for those of
you who don't know what that is it's
it's kind of like crowdfunding for
people who create content so it's it's
like a monthly payment thing monthly
really like a donation so if anybody's
interested check out my Twitter and I I
have a pin to tweet that has a link to
that I'm not gonna put a link to my
patreon on these free code cam videos
I'll put them on the videos on my own
channel but basically what I'd like to
be able to do is do more things like
this so in addition to my live streams
maybe do some streams of side projects
do some tutorial videos and you know
maybe even other things so maybe like if
more like one-on-one mentoring and
things like that so if also like
equipment right so the stream when I
show you from my house it's not nearly
as good quality as I do for my office
it'd be nice to be able to get some
better equipment you know things like
that so if you're interested and you
have a little bit to spare you know
think about you know maybe supporting me
through the patreon but you know what I
do now in terms of these live streams is
totally free it's always gonna be free
I'm not trying to charge people
especially for those of you who don't
have you know a lot of money I know how
it is starting out just learning and not
really having that much money so I want
to be able to keep doing that and maybe
even spend more time doing that
so anyway so it's it's there I'm not
gonna make a big deal about it but if if
you can donate please do and even if you
can't if you like retweet or just spread
the link around whenever you can you
know that would be that would be awesome
as well
that that's it for now I don't want to
bug you all with the patreon stuff so
let's get started and I was just just
checking real quick to see the the chat
if there's anything I need to address
first
okay
Oh Frankie yes about my Twitter and my
other channel I think my a link to my
Twitter and my other channel is in the
description to this video so check that
out and also like my I'm I'm most active
on YouTube Twitter and Instagram but I'm
on like pretty much all the social
channels so you can find me wherever you
prefer to be and I keep my my DMS open
and stuff so don't don't worry about you
know messaging me and that's totally
fine I can't always get back to you
immediately but I I try to answer you
know all my messages and if you've
messaged me and I've never messaged you
back just remind me and message me again
because it's not on purpose I just I
probably just forgot Erin says let's get
down to biz alright let me get on this
other screen what we need to I had this
there it is I knew I had it up there
okay so this way we're gonna start I'm
gonna make it a bit bigger
I see see I was just working on the my
sequel stuff so we're gonna switch over
to the Google cloud stuff and I'm
starting my Pomodoro timer on my other
screen here
okay so what I here's what I've done so
far all I've done really is just created
this FUS main site project so when you
go into my account is Franciscan
University but then within that you can
have different projects so everything we
do for this main web site for this
project five is going to be the fus main
site project okay that'll I mean that
helps to keep everything all together so
we're gonna make sure we're in that for
everything I have happen it's happened
before where I've accidentally been in
the wrong project not for for instance
can stuff it for like side project stuff
and didn't realize it until I'd already
set things up so just be careful that if
you are working on on things like this
all right so let's navigate to the
storage the storage tab and let's go
ahead and take the QuickStart so it's
not really that difficult but it it's
it'll probably be worth it to go step by
step so my face is covering this
QuickStart up so I'm gonna move myself
over to here for now because we won't be
on this side of the screen quite as much
and I'm gonna make this a bit bigger for
you all if I make it too big I the the
UI gets a little weird so hopefully
that's that's big enough and so this is
it's gonna be pretty simple we're just
gonna create the bucket basically and
then set it up for for WordPress all
right so we're in the right project this
could continue these QuickStart sorry
for for Google cloud platform so if
you've never used it and you want to get
started then
you know don't don't be too intimidated
all right so let's click create bucket
and we're gonna call this fu s WP
storage and now we need to decide you
know some of our options here so let's
go to this compare storage classes so
that we can see you know what what are
the options here so looks like they all
have 99 999 % or more availability these
three are all the same in terms of
redundancy but the multi-regional
definitely is better for that all right
so I think we're either gonna have to go
with regional or multi-regional for this
I mean I would say the the bulk of our
our visits do come from within a region
but we hope we also get visits all over
the world as well let's see
all right the costs are pretty similar
there hmm ah let's calculate I'd like to
see what monthly costs are
I
I don't know the Class A and Class B
operations are creating buckets
uploading objects deleting permissions
okay alright then that makes sense
I'll say
well her she says visits the doesn't
matter for this law in terms of the data
being access when a user does come to
the site the in let's say an image will
be served directly from this so in terms
of how many how many times like this
data is being accessed it's I think it
is relevant right or from where it's
being access to these relevant all right
let's try estimated cost actually that's
really cheap let me just Jack these up a
little bit just to get an estimated cost
it's still nice I let's see like if we
have I don't know a terabyte it's still
only twenty eight oh all right we're
we're fine we're definitely fine I
wonder why you know what I suppose
regional depends on the region for the
cost huh that doesn't twenty to thirty
one yet there's the difference between
multi multi regional and regional is so
small in cost I'm definitely gonna go
with the multi-regional especially
thinking ahead for the future the
university really wants to be able to
serve more people in a broader
geographic area so I think this would be
a better way to go all right cool let's
select multi-regional and I'm gonna
check out the Advanced Settings don't
really think I want to change them the
is encrypted automatically
yeah I'm not yeah I'm gonna let Google
handle that encryption that's not really
my specialty so I think if I mess with
it I'd be more likely to mess it up and
make it better
to
all right cool so that's it like
literally we've set up the storage
bucket right we could upload files right
now I'm not gonna do that so what I'll
do is when I'm in the office tomorrow
I will move over all of the images and
PDFs and whatever other files are being
used for the main site right now as it
is the old one I'm gonna move all those
over to here and keep the file structure
the same I don't know if you'll remember
but the way we're doing it right now is
because of most of those assets use
relative URLs we were able to bring over
the markup as is and then we just made
just a little function with that I
believe is a regular use regular
expressions and react and it just
prepends the correct URL onto that path
so right now it's prepending franciscan
dot e-d-u
because it works for now but once we
switch over where the domain name is
pointed to it's not gonna work anymore
so what we're gonna end up doing is
prepending whatever URL we have to get
access to this stuff
okay
let's continue see what else yep that's
it literally very simple that's close
all right I'm very satisfied that was
really easy so this tutorial all right
so we have a bucket
now the next step which I assume will be
slightly more difficult is setting this
up to work with WordPress so if you've
never done anything with WordPress
before don't worry I'm gonna go through
it so right now this is still the
version of toasted on digitalocean
I didn't quite get far enough this
morning I was hoping to have it all
moved over to now before I started the
stream but I ran out of time but it's
okay because whatever we do on this when
we do migrate to now we're gonna migrate
everything over as is so it's we're not
gonna have to duplicate work so I need
to go down well first of all let me make
this bigger so if you've never seen it
before this is the WordPress admin panel
let me move my face back over here so
this is the WordPress admin panel and
there are there's more than one way to
upload a plug-in it's a wordpress well
we're going to use the the admin panel
way so let's add a new plug-in and we're
gonna search for this WP stateless
plugin so there's a there's actually a
plug-in that does exactly what we want
to do already for WordPress so this is
gonna be super useful and save us a lot
of time so
really it's it's pretty simple right we
can we have different modes we're gonna
end up one with the stateless mode but
you can use this just to have Google
Storage be a backup for your WordPress
stuff we can use it as a CDN so it
copies media files and then serves them
from there or stateless where it
actually stores and serves the media
files so it's it's basically like a
combination of these two so we have no
local local meaning like on the same
servers WordPress there's no local
storage that's what we want because if
we're gonna serve this with now
basically as as if it were like a static
site that's what we need we need to take
out the database which we're doing and
we need to take out the file storage
which this will we'll do so let's
install this
and activate wonderful and it has a
setup assistance so that's great so
let's check this up Google login
all right which one this one
hasn't been verified by Google yet only
proceed yes and now like normally that
warning would mean something but I've
already researched this out beforehand
for the last few weeks so so that's why
I clicked go ahead so cookie if you do
see a warning like that with something
you're not familiar with don't just
click OK
so essentially we need to give that
plug-in permission to access our Google
storage obviously right if it needs to
be able to upload things to there then
it we need to give it access all right
so before the dual projects is fus main
site the cloud buckets is a few swp
storage great and cool so you see it's
already grabbed a lot of the stuff for
us which is awesome right when I double
clicked I got a drop-down and I could
see the project reset up so obviously it
is connected so when you work with
WordPress you can make a post like a
blog post and you have the option to
upload a file or an image right there in
the you know in browser editor so
normally that upload will just go into a
file on your WordPress server but what's
gonna happen now that we've installed
this plug-in is when we upload something
it's gonna go to our Google Cloud
Storage alright so let's do it let's try
to upload something all right we're
going to select the file actually let me
I have my file thing open I'll just drop
some stuff in there I will drop this
beautiful image that I took of myself
earlier there we go
alright so that's uploaded let's verify
and go to the media library see that we
can actually still see this from
WordPress oh yeah look at that handsome
guy I'm just joking you know all right
but there's our image we can check it
out and see like it's it's here all the
regular info awesome
who is the setting I actually want to
see these settings stateless your file
gyro replacement enable yes there we go
bucket folder yeah I do want it to be WP
folder all right so the also a part of
this private key I'm cool with that
though because there's no way you're
gonna guess the rest of the private when
I salute you from WordPress enable yep
yep so there's this is where the URLs
will actually points
if we want to we could change the domain
I may end up doing that at some point
but not today then it'd be cleaner like
it could be like I don't know like
Franciscan dot it could be like CDN dot
Franciscan dot edu right that that might
be something that we'd want to do in two
year and month based folders yes so that
year in month based folder that's the
default WordPress behavior I would like
to keep that it's um it's somewhat
useful and since that's typical
WordPress I want to keep it like that
let's save those changes greats and
check these are synchronous local so
very
yep that's what I want to do this is one
of the reasons why I really wanted this
plug-in so when you upload a file to
WordPress it automatically makes
multiple image sizes which is very
useful so what we're gonna do eventually
is we will within our react components
we'll set it up so that if we're
bringing in an image we'll use source
set and we'll select different sizes of
that image and depending on the screen
width will serve the image that is most
appropriately sized so we will save the
user a lot of data like that will get
faster load times normally that's a pain
if you have to make the image sizes
yourself but if WordPress is going to do
a for us then we can trust that assuming
that an appropriately sized image was
uploaded at first we'll have all these
different sizes to choose from so
definitely going to enable that
so obviously that first one that we just
uploaded it probably won't happen for
that
it's just compatibility with image
dropping so i'm going to able that the
force download method set which in CSS
files yeah I don't think we're gonna
have to deal with CSS so save that
alright cool
all right now let's check our bucket
let's see if we got anything in our
bucket yet hope I could refresh straight
from there wasn't looking we should have
something in our bucket although it's
possible I needed to do the settings
first oh here we go
we have a folder now let's click it the
folder was 2018 and now we have a full
for the fifth month in 2018 and whoa
check that out so here we have look at
this this is our original image we have
an image now that is 768 pixels by 1098
we have one that's 716 by 1024 we have
one that's 210 by 315 33 by 1200 we have
150 by 150 and 100 by 100 so all those
image sizes have now been created and
you can see like this is the original
354 kilobytes well let's say I don't
need that one that big let's say I'm on
a phone and I'm fine with one that's 210
by 300 now I'm down to 11 it's a huge
huge difference all right so that's
that's the benefit that we get from
allowing all these different sizes here
to come in and see and they all have
their own public links so let's just
check this out see we can see that image
right I can copy and paste this into the
chat and you all should be able to see
that image so this link can now be used
to serve images directly on our website
I don't know that's pretty cool to me I
don't know how cool it is if you've
never worked with WordPress before but I
I think it's cool enough that even if
you've never worked with WordPress as
long as you've done something with
websites before you you should probably
be able to appreciate the awesomeness of
that all right now I think my timers
about to be up yeah I got about a minute
and a half now so I'm not gonna work on
the next thing just yet I'm gonna go to
the live chat and start answering
questions and let me scroll all the way
up to the top so you can so don't miss
any of your questions
I should have said so that solution
worked that day yeah so earlier in the
stream I talked about how I got the
sequel database that we made last
Thursday to work with WordPress
Harshit had the wonderful idea of why
don't you just allow all IP addresses
and I thought yeah that's a great idea
who cares it's a test database anyway
like let's just do it and that worked so
that was all I needed basically for that
test one I just needed to see that it
worked and once I saw that it worked
I shut down the database and that was
all I needed
Daniel asked can you use Google Cloud to
push your WordPress actually I think you
can I think you can do everything right
from Google we're not gonna do the
actual WordPress installation oh sorry
sorry if that beep was super loud for
you that was my timer so let's do the
short break now for the live chat yes so
anyway the answer the question is yes I
believe you can host WordPress with
Google Cloud I'm not sure exactly how
you configure that but I think it's
possible
Gustavo's has got my first invite for a
Skype interview really excited Wow
congratulations I'm really excited for
you as well please let us know how it
goes
Oh Frankie I just saw your comment about
you saw it in the show notes don't worry
about it it's so easy to miss that stuff
I have so many links in the notes anyway
like it's totally understandable don't
worry about it
okay harsh it harsh it's making a UI
library in connection with our Java
Script AF project so let me throw that
up on the screen really quickly I'm not
have to check I don't remember the link
offhand are [ __ ] so I'm gonna go into
Twitter and grab the link that you that
you gave me in a DM okay so while this
is loading so slowly I'll read some more
questions Aaron says Pomodoro for the
wind yeah for sure
love for Maduro I need to make a video
just about how I use Pomodoro because
this has been so helpful christian asks
why did you choose Google cloud platform
over the other ones out there oh good
question good question let me explain my
my reasoning
so last week there were some different
options that we were going over so
here's why I ended up choosing Google
clouds I never heard back about whether
or not we could get a discount from
Microsoft for Azure but it seemed like
the cheapest between azor AWS and Google
cloud which were the top three that I
was considering it seemed like
Google clout was going to be the least
expensive so given that and also that I
already had gone through workshops that
was using Google cloud stuff and I have
French Francisca that works at Google
cloud I'm able to you know send her a DM
and ask questions that that was just
huge for me that the familiarity that I
already have the like we already had you
know a Google account set up for for
where I work and you know being able to
just have that that connection to
somebody that actually works there that
seemed to me like it kind of just put me
a little bit over the top and choosing
that the cool thing about this though is
that potentially and with very little
work we could switch over to a different
platform all we'd have to do is copy
over the database and then within
WordPress we just changed the WP config
file to point to that different database
and of course we'd have to find a plugin
that could connect us to that database
or modify the current plugin but really
it's but because of the way we built
this this whole project it's purposely
very flexible and you know each piece
could potentially be replaced without
that much work so if we end up getting a
good deal for Microsoft or you know
somebody totally new comes in and we
like them better then we're good this is
the UI project that Harshit is working
on so basically this is the the UI that
we're using for JavaScript AF and so
he's taking it and you know building out
a component library from that and what
will happen is I don't like it set up
right now but you should be able to
click on one of these and then get all
the markup that you need to use it you
know down here so the actual code will
be
there and these will be react components
so just you know basic right now just
starting out I think this is pretty
amazing a really simple interface to be
able to go through and see the component
so check it out I'll paste a link in the
chat if any of you want to go to it and
play with it a little bit you know but
definitely let horseshit know what you
think he's been a harsh it is harsh I
worked so hard on on all just so much
stuff side projects and on the project
we work on on the stream like I don't I
don't know how he does it all but yeah
but please let let him know what you
think I think my timer went off yet the
timer went off let me you know what let
me go through the questions the rest of
the questions here and then we'll see
what time it is and we'll decide whether
or not we want to move on now and do
some stuff with the sequel database or
because technically we've accomplished
what you want to accomplish it didn't
take that long everything worked out so
let me know what you all think now in
the chat if you'd like to keep this
short and sweet to the point and then
move on tomorrow with another stream or
if you'd like to go on a bit longer and
maybe branch out do some stuff with
sequel either way works for me probably
the deciding factor for me is gonna be
how hungry I am once I finished
answering these questions
I should ask if there's a three dollar
option on patreon I will join if it is
yes so there is on my patreon I have
different tiers of rewards I I really am
totally new to patreon so if you have
ideas for rewards please let me know
there's a poll up right now on my
patreon page of like
Awards so vote for that or if you have a
different idea just let me know I'm open
to anything I just wanted to have a few
options there just so that you can see
you know what's possible but the the
lowest tier is three dollars but you can
like if you wanted to just donate a
dollar sorry you could do that too you
know I don't think you're limited to
just the the levels of funding that I've
set there
Julio says the SLA is very low I don't
know what SLA stands for could you let
me know Julio and I'm not I don't
remember what I was doing when you said
that and what those related to maybe I
was maybe that when I was when I was
picking options for the for the storage
bucket
hey Bobby says this is awesome thanks
Bobby
I Ezekiel says hi hey Zekey how's it
going
Matt Dutchess says check out Jesse's
patreon and mad Dutchess thank you for
being a patron I really appreciate that
Xavier says it's Google storage the same
as AWS okay so Google cloud platform is
the same as AWS they're comparable so
Google storage would be comparable I
think to s3 in AWS so they're there
Google storage is just a piece of Google
cloud platform so but yeah basically
just with that little distinction I
would say yeah they're they pretty much
offer a lot of the same services Eric is
asking for thoughts on slash experience
with Magento - I have no experience with
Magento so I'm sorry about that and I
don't I don't know enough about it to
even give any anything I mean it's a
sort of look for teen eat an ecommerce
platform right see I'm gonna be even
sure what it is I believe it's an
e-commerce platform but that that's
where my knowledge stops so I don't want
to try to pretend and like I know what
I'm talking about there if anybody else
has any thoughts or experience with
Magento - please let Eric know
mad Duchess says I was first to donate
because you rock Jessie yeah for sure I
was super excited when I saw that that
was awesome so thank you I was um
yesterday I wasn't at my computer for
most of the day because it was a
Memorial Day here in the United States
that's a national holiday so a lot of
people don't have to work that day and
so usually we have like picnics so my
family I am on my mom's side I have a
really big family and they all live kind
of in the same area so we had a you know
outdoor picnic and it was a lot of fun
but like I was getting notifications on
my phone and trying to answer as best I
could and it was really sunny out so I'm
trying to like shade my eyes I can see
my screen and but I saw that and I was
just super excited so anyway thanks
again
Matt Dutchess oh so that reminds me if
any of you use a different name on
YouTube and you have a preference let me
know whether you want me to call you by
your real name or your youtube name I'm
fine either way but I just want you to
be comfortable with what I with what I
say so if you have a preference let me
know Michael crow says one good thing
about my stuttering connection is that I
get black narrow black male worthy
stills of Jessie when the buffering
occurs uh it might be fun to see some of
those I'm a little bit scared to see
someone but it might be funny there we
go actually how about this one of my
reward tiers on patreon will be you get
access to all those black male worthy
stills
CJ says I'm new to free code camp and I
just created my profile today all right
congratulations on that and welcome to
free code camp so there's so much
there's so much to free code camp so
definitely the core of free code camp is
you know free code camp org and those
lessons that's where it all started
those are super helpful to go through
those but then there's so much
supplementary material with the medium
publication and the YouTube videos and
what else we have that like Wikipedia
type thing I can't remember what we call
it that just has a wealth of information
on a ton of different coding and tech
related topics
there's a forum I'm sure I'm probably
missing something else that we do
there's a newsletter but there's just so
much so you know please take take
advantage of all these free resources
and it's it's definitely helped me to
become a better better coder obvious is
lucky you get a sunny day we have a
rainy day here at NC at NC is that North
Carolina or somewhere else
okay it is North Carolina Oracle yet I
thought it was gonna rain it it looked
like it was gonna rain for a little bit
and then it be cleared up and it was
fine it was a really nice day
it was warm kids were swimming so yeah
it ended up being really nice I actually
got some some Sun you know I as a
programmer I rarely get out right that's
the stereotype but it's actually out in
the sunlight yesterday I mean I got more
Sun yesterday than I had in like the
last two weeks combined all right cool
so I've gotten to the bottom of the chat
so let's see what time it is I don't
know I'm kind of thinking maybe maybe
I'll just we'll finish up here keep this
stream on topic for once and then yeah
we'll see maybe oh maybe we'll work on
getting everything combined together
like basically production ready tomorrow
and I'm not sure I had said before the
launch date is June 4th but potentially
it might get pushed back I don't really
want it to get pushed back but it may be
reasonable I had expected to have a
little bit more help in terms of like
data migration and cleaning up data than
I did so my original estimates were
based on that
that help which I didn't have so we'll
see we'll see how it goes I suppose it
is better to launch it and have
everything work than to try to rush it
so I'm still gonna try to do as much as
I can before the 4th but we may not
launch then either way I still would
like to have all the the setup of the
database and everything you know squared
away all right cool oh I should sit back
from dinner eating ice cream ice cream
I've been on a diet for the last like
month
ice cream sounds so good right now
alright thank you all so much for
watching I really appreciate it
I'm actually I'm really happy too
everything went perfectly that really
happens I'm really gonna try to be back
tomorrow for a stream I do have some
meetings tomorrow I can't even remember
what time they are I gotta check my
calendar so I'll do my best to let
everyone know early on in Twitter and on
Instagram what time I'm gonna stream
hopefully I get it scheduled early so
y'all can get to notifications on
YouTube yes so until then have a great
day
and thanks again for watching